Hello there, I'm Gavin.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
And today we're going to
use a very fast camera
to look at some underwater explosions.
Can use these little bangers and 1000s,
stick them in with a float.
So they sort of sit in
the middle 'cause they
actually just rise to the surface noise.
Yeah.
We also tried this before but
with the old camera, wasn't fast enough.
Yeah, we're trying to film
at 2,500 frames a second.
Today, we're going to do
28,000 frames a second.
That should really open up slow mo eyes
into what's really happening and maybe
even if we're feeling cheeky,
they're a little bit slow.
Looking forward to this.
Looking forward to it.
I'm gonna go get lighter.
Alright.
Don't try at home either.
Now the explosive creates a little sphere.
So,
I'm gonna focus on where the front of
that sphere is gonna be and
not on the banger itself.
So at the beginning, we'll
probably be out of focus,
but come into focus, hopefully.
That's cool.
A little funk.
Smells good.
Ready?
Yeah.
That's very cool.
Oh, it's like the light
comes back as it comes in
it's like all the explosive mass
has been recompressed into heat.
That's so cool.
Our camera's little
expose well really dark
just so you can see more
detail in the explosion.
That first one is pretty bright.
Quite close with your hand there.
Nah, that's fine.
Have done this before.
There's actually quite a long
way of fuse inside it, see?
Yeah, once it disappears in the film.
'Cause I swear your hand was
on it when the fuse hit the banger.
That's fine.
Look at that one little
moment in time is so cool.
That lasts for such a
small amount of time.
It's just a banger, one little banger.
Oh, man.
That was a frame and that
looked like a mushroom.
We're looking good in the middle,
We are now at 512x320 pixels,
which is shockingly bad.
Sort of lower than standard def bad
but the upside is 120,000 frames a second.
So slight issue with filming
in high speed and having to
You alright?
Got something.
Bloody hell.
Only in high speeds
where everything's dark,
but I'm also stopping
on the lens so much that
this is what I can see on the screen.
If you're struggling to see,
it's absolutely nothing.
So this will be trial and
error is in the exact framing.
No idea if we got that.
The thing is that, the
refresh rate on that screen
is so bad I didn't see anything on it.
So I have no idea what
whether we got it yet.
Struggling to find it.
Suddenly a split second.
Wait, is that the amount
of footage you've selected?
Whoa!
We got it.
Awesome, that is perfectly framed.
Very cool.
That was wicked.
Very, very cool.
So it seems like we're never gonna be able
to see the entire
explosion in full detail,
we're only gonna be able to see either
just the very beginning
or not the beginning
and some of the rest of them.
Yeah.
So we've taken different explosions,
we've got like different
stages of the explosion,
Yeah.
correctly exposed.
Okay, so I'm actually
quite interested to see
what the surface of the water
does as the explosion happens.
So we're going to position
one, a few inches under,
and do a sort of more normal frame rate.
What's a normal frame rate?
28,000.
That's not normal frame rate.
On this camera it is.
Nice.
Very nice.
Well the tank survives another video.
I don't know what we're gonna have to do
to get rid of this thing.
It's impressive.
Yeah. Although the ink
one was really pushing.
Yeah, it was.
That was crazy.
I love seeing those cavitation balls.
I'm not sure if it is just a
vacuum or whether the reaction
from the banger actually puts
air into there but it closes
in again, and sort of
reignited whatever is in there.
It is cool.
It's also interesting how
because the fuse contains
its own source of oxygen,
even if it's underwater,
you don't need to worry about it still go.
So cool.
I love to establish
ridiculous frame rates.
Well, hopefully you enjoyed that video.
I found that when fascinating.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Subscribe.
We got some second channel
for behind the scenes
and we got much.
For the T-shirt girl.
So hopefully we'll see
you in the next video.
And subscribe.
You for dip.
Oh, why it smells that?
Oh my sleeve's wet with it
What you want?
Look at that.
That would look quite cool in the summer.
Now you tell me "Go fill it back up."
Just to do that again.